say that men can menstruate is a lie and
that is now that is what is said wait
wait wait wait where did that you never
heard it right okay check it out folks
check it out anyone who says a man
cannot menstruate it's considered
transphobic I'm I'm I'm this is a far
cry from saying men can menstruate I
agree but that's not where anyone went
with that not true okay at the
University of Berkeley Men's Room
tampons are given
out check it out Cal UC see Berkeley
Men's Rooms have tampon dispensers you
would you say that's probably because
men are whipped and their
girlfriend said go get me a
tampon that's why that's a much more
logical okay all right make a friendly
bet that you that the
lgbtq normative statement is men can
menstruate